Hello and welcome to this special
edition of under the skin with me
Russell brand.
I'll be talking to doctor professor Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
I've spoken to him before,
but this special commemorative does not
really a commemorative chat.
It's not a tea towel for the raw wedding
between Meghan markle and Prince Harry.
It's a to celebrate the release on paper
back of my book recovery and look at it
now on Amazon.
It's six pound 50,
I think might be six pound 47 we talk
about that book recovery.
We talk about the principles of recovery
as a road twin light meant we talk about
Dr Peterson's book.
12 rules for life is an interesting chat
talking about myth.
We do of course go for some of the main
stays of Professor Peterson's,
a Canon of ideas that he commonly talks
about,
but also I think we really get to the
heart of it and discover some,
uh,
some people think there's an exclusion
of warmth.
I think sometimes when talking about
Peterson ideas and these,
I'm insistent on individual culpability
and responsibility.
We get into that stuff quite deeply.
I think it's a great chat.
Those.
You don't know who Jordan Peterson is
yet?
Where,
where have you been?
Obviously not watching him at the
Hammersmith Apollo with 5,000
others.
So yeah,
we were talking to Jordan Peterson and
under the skin.
Thanks for joining me and do check out
my book recovery on paperback.
Thank you
Dr.
Jordan Peterson.
Thank you for coming on under the skin.
It's lovely to see you again.
It's good to see you too.
It's nice to meet in London.
Yeah,
it's different isn't it?
We have,
both of us were exiled in Los Angeles in
our last conversation by enjoyed it very
much.
I've got a lot from it.
I'm happy to talk to you on.
This is very much home turf for me.
Now we're in London,
we're in a publishing office.
You've been promoting your book,
I presume that's why you're here.
[inaudible] and doing a public couple of
public lectures.
How do you find that now?
How do you finding what I thought in a
way,
I've been comparing you to the British
opposition leader,
Jeremy Corbyn in that you've been doing
this for ages and now you're
experiencing a,
uh,
an almost,
perhaps unprecedented level of
attention,
but I'm assuming that your skillset is
applicable.
You're a lecturer,
you're a clinical psychoanalyst,
so it's not like,
oh my God,
there's cameras.
Right,
right.
Well,
I mean,
the,
the large scale lectures aren't doing,
aren't that much different in kind from
the lectures I was doing at the
university.
I mean,
the venues are larger and yeah,
but the Hammersmith Apollo 3000 seats,
I think maybe,
yeah,
there were 5,000
at the Apollo.
Well,
that's where you're not nervous.
Um,
I'm not as nervous doing that as I am
often going to talk to journalists.
Individual journalists.
Yeah.
Because like the thing about those
venues,
there's a variety of things about them
that worked in my favor.
I mean,
I like talking to crowds,
you know,
I've always enjoyed lecturing and so
lecturing to several thousand people
isn't much different than lecturing to
several hundred people.
But I also know that the people who've
come are there happy to be there.
Like I'm,
I'm,
I'm speaking to a welcoming crowd and
so,
and it's all,
all of the details are essentially under
my control so,
so it's not it I am actually enjoying it
quite a bit.
I mean I'm apprehensive beforehand
because,
well because you should be,
you know,
I want to do a good job and I want to
make sure things go well and I want to
get through the material properly and,
and,
and get a little farther in my thinking
than I have been and I'm trying to make
each time I lecture better than the last
time and I don't,
obviously I do always don't succeed at
that but,
but it's good.
I'm enjoying it and my wife is very good
travel companion.
She's very stable and she helps me plan
my days and so we've got it down to a
bit of a routine.
I would say Tammy is in the room with
us.
We've already met previously in Los
Angeles.
You wouldn't be on mine.
There isn't in my back.
It's a just in case listeners are
wondering why perhaps they might be able
to detect in my voice.
I'm occasionally glancing towards a
spouse.
The reason is because I am now,
well,
I'm curious,
when you're,
um,
doing these lectures,
him,
he's there not a performance component.
Do you not feel like,
definitely,
yeah.
Well,
sure.
I mean a lecture theater is a theater,
you know,
and lecture is a form of theater.
Now it's a serious form of theater.
But theater can be serious,
you know,
and,
and there's a seat because partly what
I'm doing is I'm presenting ideas to an
audience,
but I'm also modeling the act of
engaging with ideas.
And that's the theatrical end of it.
And I don't give the same talk twice.
Like I have my stories and I have my
collection of things I know and I talk
about,
but I try to,
I try to do two things.
Um,
I try to,
I'm always talking to specific
individuals in the audience and so I'm
having a conversation with the audience.
And so that's,
that's part of the dynamic element of
the performance.
And the other thing I'm trying to do is
to further my thinking on the topics
that I'm addressing.
And there is a theatrical element to
that because it's,
it's like,
I think the closest thing really that it
compares to is probably stand up comedy.
Although I think the routines that
comedians have are probably more well
and formally practice than the ones
that,
that you know,
than,
than the,
than the talks that I,
that I engage in.
And I don't really think of it as
delivering a lecture to an audience.
I'm trying to think about complicated
things in real time with an audience
there to participate and to use the
audience as an indicator of whether what
I'm saying is gripping and
comprehensible.
You apprehension and,
and uh,
understandable.
Adrenaline prior to going on stage
doesn't lead you to lean into a shtick,
you know,
which would be the opposite of what
you're describing to remain
engaged in a kind of dialectic process
of discovery.
Because I find,
I mean obviously I am a comedian,
so yeah,
for us I would argue there is a,
there is a distinction between
performing for before 200 people or
5,000
people around 200 I feel like I'm very
relaxed,
I'm comfortable.
I feel like I've got a lot of space in
there.
5,000
I feel like sharpen up now you've got no
room particularly because the other
crucial difference is I,
there needs to be a laugh every 2030
seconds.
If there isn't,
it gets pretty frosty up there.
He said it is appealing to me as a
comedian.
That's interesting.
Interested in furthering intellectual
debate,
looking at their new intersections
between politics and spirituality.
Perhaps they've always been there.
These are some of these evaporating
context,
the emergence of new ideas perhaps best
exemplified by your own particular
trajectory.
Is it interesting to me that these
spaces are now becoming available for
forms of types of performance that
aren't so contingent?
It is on rapture her an opinion or what?
Right,
and I know it is a very strange thing
and I'm not sure what to make of it.
You know,
you see Sam Harris doing something quite
similar.
Richard Dawkins is doing something quite
similar and,
and it's,
I mean I was thinking because I've been
trying to conceptualize this and,
and one,
one comparable audience or one
comparable situation is probably that of
of standup comedians.
Another I suspect are traveling events,
even evangelical types because there
but,
but of course what they're doing is
explicitly religious.
This is it.
This has elements of both of those.
And what's emerging that's so
interesting is that there's a clear
public appetite for high level
intellectual conversation.
If it's,
if it's dynamic and I don't know what,
what's accounting for that all of a
sudden,
maybe it's because these sorts of
discussions aren't taking place.
Like they should in the classical media
space.
You might be right there.
Jordan,
I mean to slightly mangle to slightly
mangled the young quote that you use in
your book.
Um,
12 rules I'm really enjoying actually,
uh,
like the one could infer motivation from
results perhaps is that the political
discourse,
social discourse has become superficial
and detached from meaning from purpose,
from experience.
That there is an opening appetite for
substance,
that people are starting to what you
know.
And,
and,
and as you said about theater before,
you know,
the origins of theater and the origins
of religion a closely connected and both
of them still our debt or at least
functionally must relate to meaning
purpose,
giving us stories that help the
path.
I think that,
I think that's,
that's that's there's something about
that that's profoundly correct.
I think that,
you know,
that the New York Times has recently
written about the rise of the so called
intellectual dark web,
which is a term that Eric Weinstein so
brilliantly coined,
I would say.
And,
and very thoughtfully.
Um,
I think that the thing that unites the
people who are loosely grouped into that
collection is that they are having
serious conversations with an audience
that they respect.
And they're very diverse range of
people.
They don't certainly don't like salmon.
Sam Harrison,
I disagree about many things,
for example.
And uh,
but Sam respects his audiences and he's,
and he's engaging them in extremely
serious discourse about very deep topics
now about the structure of reality
actually.
And,
and the relationship between science and
religion and,
and,
and the,
and I think it is a consequence of the
fact that not only has our public
discourse,
let's say in the media and in politics
become shallow.
I think it's become unbearably shallow
in the universities.
So,
yeah.
Well,
because it's become so ideological,
you know,
and it's just not helpful.
Look,
I was interviewed by a New York Times
journalists last week.
Uh,
Nelly was her name and she's going to
publish this on Sunday and she did a
literature degree at Columbia.
And she told me that she was quite
appalled actually by her degree.
Uh,
especially in,
in,
in hindsight,
she told me that she didn't know until
she graduated,
that there was any other way of reading
great literature then through a
postmodern Lens.
And the postmodern lens takes a book and
basically you take a book,
whatever it happens to be,
and you decide which power hierarchy the
author was serving and who's who he's ex
or she has excluded from consideration.
So it's completely read through a
political lens as if the book is nothing
but a tool of political and economic
domination essentially.
And that's the assumption.
And like,
look,
everything's contaminated by politics
and power to some degree.
Right?
But that doesn't mean that there's
nothing to art and literature except in
service of,
of like group domination.
It's an appalling way of looking at the
world.
It would be an extraordinary bias to
bring to Jane Eyre is very difficult to
sort of make sense of it through that
Lens.
Of course you have economics and
politics who would like,
yeah,
of course important themes are going to
be present in great works of art.
But,
uh,
I,
I'm in chess,
there's still great works of art.
Yes.
The thing,
and it's like,
well,
even even with something as transient as
comedy,
let's say,
I mean,
you can't reduce comedy to the political
or the economic and,
and,
and comics who become too ideological,
let's say like musicians who become
ideal to ideological.
They're just not funny anymore.
You have to be,
I mean,
you can have your viewpoint left to
right.
That's fine.
And people do,
but you have to be able to that
viewpoint continually and you have to be
able to criticize it,
right?
Because otherwise you're not a music.
You just become a demagogue of sorts.
Yes.
I would agree that once there's a rubric
to which you
come in slave,
that becomes a dogmatic then,
then there's no room for nuance.
There's no room for hypocrisy.
Humor,
they're transcendent mirth,
chaos.
These forces need to be unleashed.
Yeah.
I think there's also things you can no
longer laugh about because you're,
you know,
you're so committed to your axioms,
you can't,
you,
you dare not transgress against them.
And if that's deadly,
if you're a comedian,
because the rule for comedy would be,
and this is something I like about,
about Sarah Silverman for example,
is she will say anything if she thinks
it's funny.
She's very daring in that manner.
Like,
I've heard her tell jokes that,
you know,
really would curl your hair,
but you can tell by watching or
something will pop into her head and
part of her golf chase,
I don't know if I should say this and
then she'll say it.
And it's often like horribly funny and
horribly funny.
It's a good kind of funny,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's daring and,
and it's something I really admire about
comedians too,
is that they'll,
they'll take that risk.
And,
and it's something also that I've found
disturbing about with regards to the
many things I find disturbing about
university campuses is that so many
comedians won't go perform on university
campuses anymore because they can't be
funny.
People get offended and it is a false,
so fen offended.
I think you're right.
I mean,
I think it's like a kind of Simon says
type of,
uh,
like him.
Do you know that game?
Do you have that game in your language?
It's just like,
are there certain things that we know
we're not allowed to say?
There's certain things that we know
we're supposed to think.
There's a kind of a,
a kind of form you like dance,
a courtly behavior.
I've heard it referred to as that we are
meant to pay homage to a particular type
of set of protocols and manners and it's
not necessarily anchored to a real
morality is not anchored to a sort of a
sense of spirit.
So we sense of love or kindness is about
like these are the rules that we abide
by.
Hm.
I want to talk to you a bit about the 12
steps and the model for handling
addiction that I've written about myself
in my book recovery cause I want to see
what you think of it a lot.
So like the 12 steps have anonymous
fellowships,
which I,
if I were to belong to them,
I wouldn't be able to say who it
belonged to them without breaching their
code of anonymity.
But,
uh,
the,
what's positive about,
uh,
this approach to addiction is a,
as we have discussed off Mike,
uh,
that it creates community like the other
people that have got a similar endeavor.
And in fact,
it was young,
the identified,
uh,
this,
this solution.
He said that like people who have got
chronic addiction addiction issues will
struggle to change.
And that's to have a spiritual
realization of some kind and the support
of a community.
Yeah.
Well I'm the spiritual realization
component that's actually supported by
the relevant addiction literature.
One of the classic cures for addiction
is spiritual transformation.
And the hardcore scientists have have
laid that out as,
as a reality in the addiction
literature.
Agree.
Because these more secular language
around that a spiritual transformation
could just be a change of perspective or
a renewal radical change of perspective
from an,
and it typically,
in my experience,
that's from a self centered view as self
obsessive view about getting your own
needs met.
Uh,
solid cystic narcissistic perspective of
low life is this is just an adventure
where I go around trying to key millay
and accrue to,
Oh wow,
I'm here to be of service.
That's of the transition in ride
microscopically.
But in addition to a community like
having connections between one another,
the 12 steps themselves,
I think are an interesting model for
transformation and shouldn't be
overlooked.
And in fact,
what my book was about.
Canton,
could that method be transposed to
anybody who's interested in change?
So I wanted to talk to you about that,
to get your perspective on them.
The first step is acknowledging that you
were powerless over your addiction and
your life has become unmanageable.
Just admitting this,
I don't want to be in this situation.
Okay,
so two,
there's two parts to that admission.
A one is that you're in trouble.
Yeah.
And I guess there's three.
You're in trouble and it's serious.
Things could be better and you don't
have the wherewithal at the moment to
make them better.
So the thing that's interesting about
that is there's a kind of radical
humiliation and humility that goes along
with that.
So you say,
I have a problem and what I know at the
moment isn't sufficient to solve it.
Great.
Because now you've opened yourself up to
the possibility of learning something as
you say,
well,
I don't know.
I don't know enough to fix this.
It's like,
okay,
well you could learn.
And one of the things that's so
interesting about people is that if they
decide they have a problem and they also
noticed that they could learn,
the probability that they will learn
goes way up.
That's very interesting.
You've actually conflated the first
three steps there in your analysis of
the first one because the first one is
admission that there's a problem.
The second one is recognizing that
things could improve,
like came to believe that power greater
nsls could restore us to sanity and the
third one has made a decision to turn
our life and our will over to the care
of God as we understood God.
So like,
you know,
yeah,
we could talk about that from a secular
goes back.
Well,
we could talk about that from a circular
perspective and say,
well there's a,
there's a higher order moral principle
that needs to be brought into the
situation.
And you sort of described that right at
the beginning of the question because
you said,
well,
what?
Partly what you do when you move from an
addicted state,
from a psychological perspective is
moved from a viewpoint of the
gratification of immediate desire.
And,
and maybe the accumulation of things as
a marker of success to the notion that
no,
you actually have a higher purpose and
that higher purpose might involve being
of service that could be of service to
yourself,
which means you wouldn't be addicted
anymore.
Cause that's not a good way of being of
service to yourself.
But I've service to yourself and the
broader community.
However you might define that,
that's a higher order purpose and it can
integrate your motivations at at a level
that doesn't leave you at the whim of
impulse.
That's the purpose of a higher order
motivation.
So okay,
so we've got three yes.
That's the first phrase to get you to
that position where you're willing to
change,
believe in the possibility of change and
accept help in order to achieve that
change.
The fourth and fifth steps are about
inventorying.
Get like this is where the 12 step
program becomes a fusion of spirituality
and psycho analysis.
Because the fourth step is a like a,
a four column method where you write
down a list of all your resentments in
your life or childhood resentments,
your resentments against the government.
People you work with,
you write it all down and then there's a
diagnostic tool where you identify what
it is in you that doesn't like that.
And,
and also interestingly in,
uh,
in 12 step,
um,
theology that's call it,
it says that anything,
anytime that you are personally
disturbed there is you have to take
responsibility for it to a degree.
There is something in you that's being
effective.
It should at least ask yourself that
question.
Is it me or is it the world?
Yes.
Well,
let's consider first the possibility
that it might be,
I wrote about that in the sixth rule,
right?
Put your herself how say yes,
yes,
am in fact,
I've got,
are the two row like my,
like I did a truncated and somewhat more
as,
uh,
linguistically explicit a,
an explorative laden version of the 12
steps.
And I've got your 12 rules for life
here.
That,
and they don't necessarily correlate,
but like,
cause like in instead of your first one,
stand up straight with your shoulders
back.
I that.
So a great chapter I think I love about,
you know,
the lobster staff and this sort of the
uh,
the ancient,
timeless,
all most roots of hierarchies and the
chemicals that are at play.
What's happening when you're,
what does that play when we talk about
self esteem?
Um,
I like and the year the six one set your
own house in perfect order.
I suppose before you criticise the world
steps four and five in the tea in a 12
step program,
deal with that inventory.
What's going on in your life,
inventory,
what your baggage is in your own
personal think.
It's very practical down.
It's like,
well let's say you want to fix up your
house,
which is actually quite a lot like
fixing yourself up,
which is a very common dream.
Metaphoric attic.
Well,
the first thing you want to do is go
look around and see what needs to be
fixed.
You know,
and,
and that's the interesting thing about
that.
This is a kin to what comedians too,
is that as soon as you're willing to
admit Comedians,
look at a problem and then rise above it
right away and make a joke about it.
But as soon as you're willing to admit
that you have a problem,
then you're immediately contacted the
part of yourself that's at least strong
enough to admit that you have a problem.
And so,
so the act of admitting the problem is
actually the first step to solving it.
You might say,
well,
and it's an optimistic step because you,
you might say,
oh my God,
I can't admit to I that I have a problem
because what if I can't solve it?
Or,
exactly.
So then maybe you won't admit to it.
If you do to it,
you're a simile.
Tanium admitting to the possibility that
you could solve it and then it can
actually become something that's
optimistic.
You can say,
well,
my life is horrible.
It's like,
okay,
but I'm doing 50 things wrong.
Well Great.
I could fix those things and then maybe
it wouldn't be so horrible.
It demonstrates the admission itself
demonstrates progression and possibility
for further progression.
I think it relates,
that's why humility is always stressed
in,
in great religious traditions.
Humility is precisely that.
It's like you have to look at why you're
not so good.
Yeah,
and and you know that that has to break
down your pride to some degree in your
arrogance.
It's like,
well that's great because if you break
down your pride in your arrogance,
then your prime to learn and you can
solve your problems.
So there's nothing in that.
It's a bit crushing to begin with
because you might think,
oh my God,
they're pretty,
a lot of things wrong with me,
but at least then you're on the on the
road to fixing them.
My pesonal Janay recovery has been a
good,
like a kind of death.
It like,
you know,
look at that.
When I was 27 it was like the death of
the drug addict self.
That guy dies funny because I told Tammy
when we were coming here today that when
you were 27 you made the decision to
live.
I knew it was 27 because that's when
people,
I'm going to say like cue,
but you know celebrities who,
who are sort of on fire,
they die all the time at 27 because they
don't make that decision.
They decided that they don't decide that
they're going to take that final step
into maturation.
They want to hold on to that Peter Pan
thing that that pause you bet you
exactly that.
They want to hold on to that and you,
you can't hold onto that and live.
Yes.
And then there's a further death,
I'm noticing now in my early forties so
that like,
ah,
now like the midway point at the Nicoe
and that sort of Dante Esquire,
ah,
I'm,
and now I'm moving towards the grave and
now I'm at like,
there's a different kind of alertness
and merging and back to this step four
and 5 million in this process of
inventorying.
After you've made an imagery and you've,
you've correctly,
you've honestly and openly put down
everything,
incidents of child abuse,
things that you've said to other people,
things that your shame.
Once you've been willing to inscribe
your shame,
then you tell another person,
a person that you trust.
In the original literature it says,
you know,
it could be a cleric or doctor or
whatever.
It typically in a,
in 12 step structures,
it's like a mentor figure,
but that has the,
that's the role of confession,
which obviously a huge part of psycho
analysis.
The point in your book,
I think this pertains to is when you
took that the dragon and the dragon that
you said there was that kid's book that
you read where it talks about the dragon
getting bigger and bigger.
If it's not identified.
I think four and five are somewhat like
that.
Yeah.
We'll end.
Part of the point of that kid's book is
that as soon as you turn around and look
at something,
it tends to shrink.
And that's partly because imagine that
you have a memory that you won't
confront.
Well,
there's something in that memory that's
terrifying,
but,
and that means it's sort of associated
with everything else that's terrifying.
And so it's horror.
It's a horrible,
but then when you turn around and look
at it,
you think,
yeah,
it's horrible,
but it's,
it's horrible in this precise and
defined way.
And that takes it away from all the
other potential horrors of it.
It starts to shrink it right away and
also makes you into the thing that can
turn around and look at the horror,
which is a real,
real positive transformation lacked on
your part.
So it's true that somehow in be in being
prescriptive and being specific,
the problem becomes manageable because
otherwise it's limitless.
It becomes a apocalyptic in the end is,
well,
what's the worst thing that's Kevin is I
could be destroyed.
And everyone I love could be destroyed
and of itself could be destroyed.
And until you say,
well,
actually,
you know what this is is you feel
inadequate because you weren't role
models.
Correct.
There's all right,
well I can maybe take care of that.
It's still bad,
but it's not everything.
And then you,
you phrased that exactly right is that
without that attentive delimiting it
becomes apocalyptic.
That and that,
that's a very,
very old idea.
So one of the things that happens in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
the Enuma elish is that the guards are
created there.
There,
there are the offspring of chaos.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And they become very careless and they
destroy their category system.
They destroy their father essentially.
And chaos comes flooding back.
And that's what happens to people who
aren't looking at things and delimiting
them properly.
They become up apocalyptic and do the
mint.
So,
but sometimes in a nithya there is the
positive,
um,
fantech confronting of the God aeg
Prometheus's.
So sometimes we need to steal,
steal the fire.
Sometimes we need to challenge these
orthodoxies,
don't we?
Yesterday?
Absolutely.
I mean part,
part of the,
well part of the death that you're
describing is actually the confrontation
with a form of tyrant.
Like your previously addicted self was
the tyrant over your emergent self.
Yes.
And so it's an internal tyrant and you
said it was predicated on a false value
system.
That's a false set of God's essentially.
And so you had to confront that that is
a kind of death.
I also think that some of the addiction
or addictive tendencies,
and I don't mean as severe as chemical
dependency or forms of addiction
addiction or a kind of self constructed
formaldehyde to preserve you in the
state of trauma,
that trauma is acknowledged.
No means to navigate trauma are present
because of the isolation.
Because you have no mentor,
you have no,
you have no doc Trin,
you have no community.
So addiction steps in,
this is how our preserve,
this is how I will not die.
I will find this repeat notice.
There is a habit,
a repeated pattern to sustain you,
a holding pattern so that you don't die
because there is no way out.
There's no guide,
there's no path.
You'll just in the forest and there
isn't a way out.
So I feel that addiction for a personal
experience and that I,
I hope and suspect more broadly is a
means for sort of status for
preservation.
After trauma,
the rupture occurs is not addressed and
a means for survival and merges in the
form of addiction.
Addiction is not your nemesis.
He is your friend at least while you're,
you know,
in,
whilst you're in war,
there's certainly a literature
on addiction that indicates that many
people use addictive substances as a
form of self medication and they tend to
find the drug that best,
best medicates them,
let's say,
and for different people.
That's different drugs.
Yes.
Yeah.
Now see,
one of the other things that I'm
proposing in my book is to use Roth
grandiose terminology is that the,
uh,
that the template for a recovery from
obvious forms of addiction could be
applicable to less evident forms of
addiction.
I eat just patterns and habits and
because we're so far,
the things you've laid out would be,
would be in keeping with that idea.
Well,
you admit to the problem.
I really also,
I think the idea of laying out your
resentments is unbelievably useful
because that's also a way of dealing
with the malevolence within you that
might interfere with your own recovery
because you're angry at yourself.
If you're angry at your parents,
if you're angry at the world,
the probability that you're going to be
in the mental state that's going to
allow you to charge deposit of course
for yourself is very,
very low.
How can you have a clear and authentic
relationship with your wife if you've
not correctly understood what you feel
about your own mother?
If you feel like that you are immeshed
or trapped in some way,
how am I supposed to have an or if I've
not understood that if I've not gained a
new perspective,
if I've not transcended it by sharing
it?
Another,
pursue that in,
in,
in the sleeping beauty story and the
Disney story,
when the prince is encapsulated in a
castle in the dungeon at the end and
before he goes and rescue sleeping
beauty,
he has to confront his terrible mother.
She turns into the dragon of chaos
itself.
He has to use honesty and truth to
confront her.
And until he does that,
he can't free the maiden from her sleep.
Yeah.
So that's called the,
that's called the freeing of the anima
from the negative mother archetype and
union psychology.
It's precisely that and that,
and that negative feminine will be
overlaid on your partner unless you,
unless you're able to clarify it and
clarify your relationship with it.
And that could be something like
overprotection or it could,
you know,
in your past or it could be neglect for
that matter or it could be the rejection
at many,
at the hands of many,
many women before you encountered this
woman and that then you are going to
bring that bitterness forward as a kind
of projection.
If we are unwilling to undertake this
kind of excavation,
then we are doomed to continually have
relationships that are cutaneous just to
the superficial coordinates will govern
our experience in pronation ships.
So that's the repetition compulsion from
a Freudian perspective is that that
isn't how Freud explained it.
That's how it union would explain it.
But,
but the simple explanation of it is,
well,
if you bring the same set of precise,
unexamined presuppositions to every
situation,
the same fate will play out.
You might say,
well,
all those women are the same.
It's like,
well actually no,
but the part of the part of them that
you're able to make contact with acts
the same every time.
That's a very different thing.
Brilliant.
And this is where six and seven the next
steps are chronologically occur,
but
there's six.
Having done this inventory,
you recognize what patterns have been at
play in your life,
which particular in the lexicon of the
recovery defects of character of
governed you often pride wanting to
control other people's perspective,
self pity,
self centeredness,
intolerance in patients,
greed,
jealousy,
envy,
lust,
sloth.
That's where you identify the seven
deadly sins and how they play out in
your life essentially.
Yes.
And so,
and you become in the six step six is
about becoming willing to live
differently.
Saying I argue,
actually willing to let go of last.
Are you or do you like last when it
comes to it?
Do you like being impatient?
Does it serve you in some way to be
slothful?
It's highly probable that it does.
Yes.
You know,
it's,
it's easy.
It's gratifying,
it's powerful,
it's pleasurable,
especially in the short term.
Like there's lots of,
there are reasons that people are
tempted by,
by the seven deadly sins kind of
glorious there.
Dot.
Laurie and they have a wrong,
that's exactly right.
There's a dark romantic and he really
see that in the deaths of celebrities
around 27 is they,
they fall in love with the allure of
that kind of have that romantic death
and it does the men,
so the Anti Libido,
the dark libido,
the death force.
So with the,
once you have diagnosed,
which particular defects of character of
being most prominent in your path and
become willing to let go of them,
this like at step seven is making a
concerted and real effort to live
without them.
And this is where it kind of becomes to
sacrifice theory.
That's what are you willing to sacrifice
in order to move forward?
You have to give up something that you
love and you may have to give up the
thing you love the best.
That's the fundamental sacrificial
Motif,
sacrifices and an unattractive idea in
our self,
in,
in our society that's based on consuming
and indulgence.
And this is not something that I would
lay,
this is again,
perhaps you were,
you and I somewhat differ is that I
would not,
whilst this will not change without the
individual's engagement,
a kind of step one and acknowledgement
that it needs to be changed.
This is where I say there is a social
responsibility,
but for whatever reason our society has
become a manifestation of these darker
impulses.
These are the prevalent foresees,
at least in the kind of society,
Ilumien,
I don't know what it's like to live in
China or Libya.
I'm just saying like in London,
like what your kitchen with immediate
gratification,
too much emphasis on because immediate
gratification is a tool of consumerism.
This would be my argument.
Um,
so like,
but at this point in the program,
it's where the,
the spirituality becomes,
I find personally undeniable that you
have to,
uh,
you have to call to something else.
You have to in a sense,
be lay yourself open.
The idea of prayer becomes quite
important now.
So there's a,
there's a union idea there.
So the union itself is the thing that
guides the Eagle through
transformations.
So managing the ego,
which is what you think you are.
Or the thing about the ego is the ego
can be wrong
and the ego can die and be reborn.
So what that indicates is that there's
something underneath the ego.
It can guide that process of
transformation.
And partly what you're calling on when
you call on this higher power is at
least from a psychological perspective,
it's a decision to rely on that thing
that can guide you through
transformation.
Yes.
Because surely as we said in relation to
another,
we are likely relate into a set of
coordinates that we impose on Info
Commerce,
the female,
the true same would be true of the cells
that we have created,
an impression and egoic impression.
We have constructed an artificial self,
but beneath it there is our higher self
or an alterior self that can often
composed of,
it's often composed of things that you
refuse to or would we're willing to
develop.
And so when young talks about,
for example,
the incorporation of the shadow was that
you've constructed a Nigo and there's
things it can do and can't do,
that it's allowed to do and it isn't
allowed to do.
And then there's a shadow domain that
would consist of those things that you
could do but haven't.
And some of that's terrible,
but some of it's what you need to break
free w uh,
infinite variety in the shadow or are
there sort of templates there?
Would you say that,
you know,
a common component of the show,
she's last aggression aggression too
because they're the most,
the two that are mobilized.
Yeah.
They're the two that are most difficult
to integrate into the ego because
aggression destroys and of course lost.
Subsumes the individual too,
too,
too well to sexual sexual desire is such
a lusty zipper identified as a very
powerful self.
It can,
it can subsume.
So I suppose that's why a lot of
theological doctrines focus on the
control of last another.
There is,
of course,
it's a disruptive force,
you know,
because for example,
if you make a medium to longterm
relationship with someone in knew,
negotiate that,
that provides you with a stable
structure that can operate across your
entire life.
It's good for you,
it's good for them,
it's good for your kids,
it's good for society.
But then if you're really attracted to
someone momentarily,
you can be driven to act on that.
And every,
all the rest of that can burn up.
It's not good.
And so it's no wonder that it's viewed
as a,
a force of tremendous disruption.
Now it's also a force of tremendous
life,
right?
Because you want to be attracted to
people.
You want to have that,
that,
that vital libido is part of,
part of what's driving you forward.
But hopefully it's on your side and not
working against you.
And so,
you know,
if you're successful and you've put
yourself together and you're
disciplined,
you should still be maximally sexually
attractive,
but it should be under your control.
You're not,
uh,
you're not the puppet of that force
anymore.
It's integrated into you and that's a
much better way to manage it.
How do you,
uh,
in your understanding,
how is the shadow incorporated?
What rituals,
what ceremonies,
what behaviors successfully incorporate
a shadow,
say in the,
using the example of lust with what's a
way back in for the sort of,
uh,
for,
for lust,
there's been disembodied or repressed?
What's a safe way for it back?
Is there one?
Well,
I think part of it is to,
is to admit to your desires within your
own relationship.
You know,
cause you might say,
well,
I'm,
I'm tired of my wife.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe you're tired of the games that
you're intelligent enough to play with
your wife,
but she's as plural potential as you
are.
And so you have to admit to your
desires,
let's say,
and maybe you have to make them
consciously manifest within your own
relationship.
And then you know when people can do
that,
people do that by,
by dressing up or by,
by playing sexually.
I would say my play exactly that play as
a transformative element.
And that's a,
you know,
and it might be that you're
uncomfortable with the idea of,
of your wife as sexual play thing
because you think that a woman who's
married should be proper and Prim and
should only behave sexually in a certain
way,
in which case,
well that becomes stale and dull and
you're more likely to be tempted by
something on the outside.
For me,
that's a very obvious example of how
habitualized thinking is prohibitive
even without reaching the extremes of
self destructive,
addictive tendencies.
If I have a habit of regarding my wife
as as object day,
even if that's not a objectification as
we are typically taking,
but you know,
limiting beliefs about my wife,
the,
the tools that break down addictive,
uh,
the thought patterns could be used to
create new terrains,
new liberty,
new play.
Thank you.
Um,
so like,
so once you've done up to step seven,
which is essentially the steps in,
and you're right,
it's sort of sacrifice of the old self
and handing over to the,
some kind of sublime divine self,
um,
that that step eight is you make a list
of people that you have harmed and
become willing to make amends to them.
So you look back at your path and go,
God,
I shouldn't have stolen that.
I shouldn't have done that.
I treated that person badly.
That was wrong.
I lied.
So its moral,
it becomes quite a moral monster.
Real repentance,
right?
And atonement atonement is at one meant.
And if you're a caring transgressions
that you regard as transgressions now in
your life,
then you don't want to carry those
forward.
You want to,
you want to,
you want to step forward in life without
that moral burden because you will have
contempt for yourself otherwise and you
won't take care of yourself.
It also,
uh,
in a sense we were talking about it,
about allowing lust backend incorporate
in last just then,
uh,
this is a more,
a broader method for incorporating
annexed aspects of the self.
Like,
you know,
how can you fully love,
how can I fully love myself if I know I
treat it that person abominably well,
if I go back and say that was wrong,
I did you wrong.
I owe you an amends.
You are,
you invite that part of your life in,
you amend your path through life as well
as teaching yourself that that is not
the way we proceed any more.
That's their pay.
And,
and that's a real,
that's,
that's taking our,
that's real action in the world.
It's not a hypothetical at that point,
right?
It's kind of like telling people what
you've written down about your,
uh,
about your faults.
Yes.
Because it makes it real.
When you,
when you're acting it out with someone
else,
it's not only a mental thing at that
point.
Furthermore indicates step by step eight
is done separately.
The step eight is right out the list.
People.
Step nine is now going through it.
It makes the distinction,
I think to create a space for you where
you're not going,
where you're not continually thinking.
I don't know if I can do in that.
I'm not going to apologize.
I was abused by them.
Fuck that.
They did as much wrong as I did,
which is not the point,
right?
It's not the point.
And also I think we might've done more
wrong than you do.
Yes,
but you're still stuck with the fact
that you did something wrong.
That's wrong,
that's not good.
And if you refuse to surmount the
obstacle over,
like you know,
some arbitrary measure of who is more
wrong,
then you continue to cast yourself in
victim hood.
You have no personal autonomy shoes to
go for it.
It doesn't matter if you're only 5% at
fault and it also doesn't matter if the
other person apologizes to you.
They should.
It would be better for them.
It might make things worse.
Layout,
that's not the point and this perhaps is
where what I think is significant that
now your life has become not negotiation
between you and other billy beings as
they materially present themselves,
but between yourself and this higher
purpose that has been declared earlier,
that you are now operating on the in a
very calm,
a spiritual plane.
You are no longer about.
If I do that,
I'll get that.
It precisely doesn't matter if they have
a person goes,
I don't care if you apologize or not.
Super religious language that would be
expressed as the discovery of your
father in heaven instead of your earthly
father because your father in heaven
would be the higher spiritual authority
to which you all allegiance.
And you can think about that either in
religious terms or a nonreligious terms.
Is that what you've done is you've in
some sense as you've abstracted the,
the idea of a higher authority and a
higher purpose and you've decided to
devote yourself to that.
That's a religious app and that's
precisely antithetical to postmodernism
is saying that they're,
no,
no.
There is an essence,
there is a category,
there is a way.
There is.
That's right.
That's,
that's,
that's what is precisely antithetical.
Yes.
Because the postmodern claim is that
there are multiple ways of looking at
the world.
Many ways that's true,
but the antithesis of that is yes.
Just because there's multiple ways of
looking at the world doesn't mean there
are multiple proper ways of looking at
the ways.
In fact,
there's a very narrow range of proper
ways of looking at the world.
My,
uh,
my concern with atheism has always been,
it's sort of easy affiliation with
nihilism or why don't we just wondering,
it's not fucking people.
Then that sort of like,
that's like,
that's where my mind immediately goes,
if there is not an order,
why not just smash everything to
smithereens?
And you're saying ideologically that is
what's happening ideologically with
deconstructing God.
We are de deconstructing morality
without for sure do gender.
We're deconstructing that was the danger
that both both nature and dusty Husky
pointed to clearly.
It's like you dispense with the
transcendent principle and you open up
the landscape for impulsive nihilism.
What are they responding to?
Post enlightenment rationalism?
Is that,
what does the Husky in nature responding
to why they run,
responding essentially to the idea of
the death of God,
both of them and,
and that explicitly.
And he's that an enlightenment idea.
Like where is that?
Where he's deaf of God happened in the
house.
Should be at the hands of a,
of a kind of arrogant and narrow
rationalism and the materialism.
Yeah.
And the exposition of,
or the,
the exponentially that has led us to
where we're going now,
which is a kind of,
okay,
we're,
we're sort of digging the earth from
beneath our feet,
putting ourselves into the abyss.
That's right.
That's,
that's the,
that's the hypothesis.
Precisely.
Yes.
10,
11.
The last three steps.
Step 10 is,
uh,
like a continue to make inventory.
So like let this process continue like
on a day.
For me in psycho analytic terms,
I see a therapist obviously like,
like it's when like when there's a
moment I know any spike in my energy.
If I go,
oh,
I felt something that was interesting.
I felt jealous there or I felt I felt
small in that moment.
These are the moments I know and go,
well,
how was I participate in that?
What belief of mine was being
challenged?
Is that a helpful belief?
Belief being a thought that I like
having an 11 right?
That's a kind of consciousness is like,
well,
I'm going to fall apart.
I'm going to make mistakes.
I don't want to make mistakes.
I'm going to keep an eye out for when I
do make mistakes and I'm going to make
them conscious and then I'm going to try
and work on them.
Yes.
Bringing them into into consciousness
cause my fear,
my number one thing on a personal level,
possibly on a social level,
I don't know quite how to extrapolate or
conflate those two notions is
unconsciousness.
I've get very afraid when I'm dealing
with unconscious individuals.
When Pete,
when I'm,
people don't know why they're doing what
they're doing.
You may see this in sort of violent rage
or even in less dramatic or theatrical
behaviors.
And I feel there's a great idea that
lurks at the bottom of the Christian
mythological tradition is that a little
bit of consciousness destroyed the
original paradise.
We became conscious enough to be aware
of our own mortality.
But the cure for that is way more
consciousness,
not a return to unconsciousness.
Yes,
there's no going back.
There's no going back.
I sometimes think the plethora of Zombie
movies is,
you know,
they don't know they're already dead.
Um,
like so like that danger of the Zombie
is the danger of the desire for
unconsciousness as a,
as a solution to life's problems.
And I think that this is again,
something we're being invited to
participate in through consumerism that
live your life continually on the
frequency of unconscious energy,
such as desire and fear that we're not
being,
we're not being invited to participate
on their level of consciousness,
conscious interaction,
presence in the moment.
While you could make that case if you
made the case that consumerism promotes
the gratification of immediate desires
above all else.
I think he does.
That's my,
that's what I'm pushing forward with
this original sin like,
so a little bit of consciousness is a
dangerous thing.
We've become aware of our vulnerability,
our mortality,
our nakedness,
corporeal nature.
But the solution to this is to,
to become more conscious to,
we have to.
So,
uh,
how do you,
how was that?
Did you have the whole rest of the
Bible?
Yes.
Grinding.
Where does that get resolved now when
they get kicked out of the garden?
Part of,
part of what happens in,
in the,
in the redemptive story is if you think
about Christ as a symbolic figure,
say a symbolic of the process of
transformation that we just described is
one of the,
one of the morals of the Christian
passion is that you need to radically
accept your limitations.
And so part of this keeping your sins
before your eyes,
which you just described,
here's all the ways that I fall short of
the glory of God.
Let's say,
you know,
I make this mistake,
I made this mistake.
That's all consciousness.
And it's painful,
right?
Because you think,
well,
you become more conscious.
It's this glorious process of
enlightenment.
And overall it is.
But the details are exactly this.
The things you need to become
consciousness,
conscious of our precisely,
those things that you least want to
become conscious of.
And that this is the Motif that you've
identified in the alchemical tradition,
because the whole chemical,
the chemical motto,
so to speak,
was that which you most need to be
found,
that which you most need to find will be
found where you least want to look.
Right?
Yes.
And everyone knows that's true.
Like you tell someone that they go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
that's,
I know that's true.
So,
and that's also the greatest barrier to
enlightenment,
because if a night moon was all,
you know,
tulips and,
and sunshine,
then everyone would be enlightened.
But it's not.
It's this continual bringing before
yourself,
all your proclivity for,
for transgression.
And that's that and that obviously
because how are you going to solve your
problems if you're not aware of them?
Hey,
we don't want to,
we all discipline today,
Jordan.
Well,
it's not surprising,
but the alternative is far worse.
That's the thing and that is the display
because I was very curious.
I was very curious.
Like I said,
I talked about this with Tammy when you
were coming here.
I thought Russell decided to live when
he was 27 I can't.
I would like to know why.
So why did you make the decision to,
to not allow what was consuming you to
kill you?
In a sense,
he was taken out of my hands for the
first time.
I encountered positive of male or 40
figures,
curiously like,
or at least that we're able to address
that in particular,
I was sent to a treatment center.
I had free months.
I had time to think.
I had time to let I,
I passed from childhood directly into
addictive behaviors.
In fact,
those addictive behaviors are already
present in childhood in a less toxic
form in a,
my relationship.
In retrospect,
we've,
chocolate was addictive.
My relationship with pornography as an
adolescent addictive,
I was using it to,
for medical medical purposes.
So,
so when substances became an option in
adolescents,
it was seamless.
And that meant that my emotional and in
my emotional growth was arrested at that
point.
The reason I was able to stop is because
inadvertent,
I was offered help.
I got,
I was given help our people that the
management company that was working with
your cf of drug addicts,
you should go away.
Okay.
So partly that meant that re they
regarded
you as the sort of valuable commodity
that was worth preserving.
Yes.
There was a degree of that,
right?
Well,
no,
but that's helpful.
I mean,
regardless,
so even if it's purely an economic
interest,
there's,
so there's something to that.
Yeah.
So and so then you went into treatment
and you found some people that I went,
it was run by an atheist,
a chip Thomas,
but the 12 step principles,
you can't unpick it from the Oxford
Group.
First Century Christian group.
You know,
there's the,
and the,
and I'm,
for me it's more appealing when you talk
about it in Uni in terms of though I
have no problem with the sublime and the
divine live for that shit.
But like,
like I was always trying to get out of
my head off my face.
Those were the things I wanted a sublime
experience and experience of what is
beyond the material.
That's what I want to know.
So like it was,
but once I was in that environment and
like given drugs to help where I was
addicted to opiates,
so I recommend a drug called subutex Dan
and sleeping pills because I couldn't
sleep.
And during that time,
I suppose in a way I didn't fully
address the issue of addiction because
my,
I was really promiscuous for about a
decade that I,
those,
that behavior was transplant it kind of
effortlessly.
But I do remember a kind of moment of
epiphany.
Epiphany is revelation of previously
concealed truth when it first occurred
to me,
you,
I suppose you don't have to take drugs
every day.
I remember that thought entering and it
being sort of like,
oh yeah,
I'd never thought about that cause that
will,
I'd found a solution.
It worked in,
worked as a way of managing pain,
prevent in forever mental investigation
or discovery of conclusions that would
have been unhelpful and that wouldn't
have been able to deal with.
I think in a lot of cases,
and I'm sure there's many,
many variables,
uh,
that,
that actually chemical dependency as a
successful technique for preventing
suicide.
That there is just,
this is a holding pattern to stop me
doing something more dramatic and band,
unless people have access to an
ideology,
a structure and support that will help
them through that.
There's,
it's very difficult to overcome.
And I was fortunate in that I was
granted that and then granted this
system.
And so,
and as I've been working in it,
I've come to the conclusion that it is
possibly universal,
not because I think it's derived from
universal ideas.
That's why I think young I made that,
that identified,
Oh,
if,
if some,
like if there's a spiritual experience
and then the support for community,
that's how someone could be stopped from
drinking continually alcoholic drinking.
And then they took this process where
the 12th original 12 step fellowships
took the Oxford group had a program of a
sort of redemption and restitution and,
and like it seems initially in a,
I think in a materialistic society
counter intuitive to think that the
solution to addiction is going to be
super spiritual awakening.
But that's what it is.
And the,
the final steps,
I'll stay connected once you wrote,
like you're continually inventorying the
moment we think,
oh,
I felt something there.
Yeah.
That you want to be in the moment
connected.
Like,
and I have to know is if I,
if someone makes me feel inferior or if
someone,
if I'm sexually attracted to someone,
those are the most obvious examples of
something that will take me out of my
connection and that the,
the final step is,
uh,
made it,
is,
uh,
help others and remain awake.
Right.
Well that's the end of the hero's
journey is once you go into the darkness
and find something of value,
the next thing to do is to distributed,
distributed within the community to
bring it back and distributed within the
community.
Yes.
Now told and D is it like it would be
difficult for me to accept that you've
not been a sort of personally affected
and are not personally angry rather than
just,
um,
objectively because your personal
trajectory I suppose in the public eye
at least began with the situation in
Canada with a sort of forced speech or
however it's termed now.
You know,
so like that they,
are you able to distinguish between your
sort of sense of personal irritation
because,
well,
I think for most people,
and tell me what were,
whether or not you think that he's
right,
that academia seems like,
um,
uh,
an ancillary area.
It doesn't seem mainstream to most
people.
Like,
but to you it seems as though it's a
very,
very vital,
but you are an academic.
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
so there's,
there's two things there.
I mean people regard academia as
ancillary,
but it's not the reason.
It's not as because the universities
train the people who run things and so
whatever's mainstream in the
universities right now,
even though it's separate from society,
is going to be mainstream everywhere
five years down the road.
And so that's,
that's a big brawl against the vanguard
academia.
There's no,
do you think what's happening now in
terms of a media and politics?
You could,
uh,
could say you could preemptively if
diagnosed that from what's happening
five,
10 years?
No,
I,
I think,
I think that in some sense I was
preemptively diagnosing it because I've
been watching the politically correct
postmodern types for quite a long time.
And one of the C,
one of the things I noticed about five
years ago,
six years ago,
there were two things that I noticed
that I really didn't like.
The first is that because I'm a
personality psychologist,
as a researcher,
not as a clinician,
but as a researcher,
I,
I know the literature on gender
differences in personality because it's
part of my field.
And I could tell that I was starting to
have some reluctance to deliver the
lecture on gender differences.
And now I didn't stop.
But I,
I felt,
I felt that I was treading on thin ice
by delivering those lectures.
And I thought,
oh,
that's not good because I'm like a
comedian.
I'm pretty much willing to say anything
that I think is true and,
and you know,
regardless of the consequences in some
sense,
because I'd rather take the consequences
of what's true.
And I thought this isn't good because if
someone like me who's,
you know,
rather,
um,
uncontrollably mouthy,
let's say it's starting to have second
thoughts about teaching,
what's a very serious topic and,
and,
and something about which there's a very
well developed science then how much are
other people starting to censor?
And at the same time,
my students,
many of whom were female,
were telling me that they were really
hesitant to talk about gender
differences in any of the courses they
were running.
And I thought,
oh,
this is not good.
This is seriously not good.
And so,
and it's certainly the case that,
that my colleagues censor themselves
increasingly on campus with regards to
the topics they're willing to discuss.
And it's subtle,
you know,
because imagine in a given lecture I
could discuss any of 10 things and three
of them are taboo.
Well,
I just won't discuss those,
you know?
And that's that.
That's a kind of invisible censorship.
It's not like I'll get up and say,
look,
I could have talked to you about gender
differences in personality,
but I won't because I'm afraid I'll just
pick another topic because there's lots
of topics to choose from.
And that means there's going to be a
bunch of topics that are really
important because actually the issue of
sex differences in personality happens
to be really important that people just
won't talk about.
And the other thing that's so annoying
about this is that,
especially with regards to sex
differences in personality,
well,
let's say,
let's say that you're firmly on the side
of women just for the sake of argument.
Well,
you admit to or deny the existence of
sex differences in personality.
What's better for women?
Well,
you know,
the radical left is basically say,
oh well those,
if you talk about sex differences,
then you're part of the oppressive
patriarchy and you're attributing to
women a different kind of temperament in
the attempt to continue the suppression.
But I could just as easily say,
it's like,
well,
wait a second.
Like if you want to,
if you want to,
uh,
give the individual the greatest degree
of freedom,
you say,
look,
you,
you're different from another person.
You're different on the basis of a
variety of your characteristics,
sex being one of them,
that's going to have some effect on what
sort of choices you want to make in your
life.
It's like go ahead and make whatever
choices you want as far as their direct
expression of your being.
And so if you deny the existence of
these sex differences,
which no one,
no serious commentator in the
psychological literature,
in the personality domain,
and those are the people to know about
this thing,
nobody debates whether or not sex
differences in personality exist or that
they have a biological component.
No.
See.
And what's also interesting about that
is that none of those people are
conservatives.
There are no conservative psychological
researchers to speak of there in a tiny
minority.
So the people that have done the
research indicating that there are
differences between the sexes and
personality,
and that those differences have a
biological,
in part a biological component.
Those are liberal and left leaning.
People who've drawn those conclusions
despite their,
you know,
despite what their ideological
presuppositions might have suggested to
them to begin with.
So,
well,
so you know,
it's,
I don't know what to say about that
except that it's,
it's all appalling.
I suppose the fear must be that
difference will ultimately be used for
leverage,
for status that sure,
that's a reasonable fear,
you know,
because because anything can be
manipulated but,
but claims of identity can have identity
claims that,
that people are identical in some way
can also be used for the same reason.
You know,
if I insist that everyone is exactly the
same on all dimensions,
that there's just as much of a
totalitarian threat lurking in there as
there is the threat lurking that we'll
use differences as an excuse.
Yeah.
And we're also not having a serious
discussion about this.
It's like,
yeah,
there are men are overrepresented at the
top of the economic apex.
That's true.
It's a small minority of men by the way.
It's certainly not men in general,
but they're radically underrepresented
at the board,
overrepresented at the bottom.
And believe me man,
like nobody cares about men who are
failures.
They are like off the bloody radar.
Yeah.
So and,
and there's no sympathy for men who are
failures.
So men stock up at the top and the
bottom and,
and,
and we don't have a discussion about
that and we don't have a discussion
about the fact that women are radically
underrepresented in dangerous jobs,
although they are or in or in or in,
in trades that require like brutal
physical labor.
Women are radically underrepresented
orange,
orange jobs outside women are radically
underrepresented.
So the complaint is always,
well,
if you look at the top 1%,
it's there are more men than there
should be.
You know,
by pure sex division.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
but if you look at the bottom,
the reverse is true.
So if we're going to have the
discussion,
which are,
and I don't really necessarily think we
should have that discussion,
but if we're going to have the
discussion,
then we should look across the entire
economic spectrum.
I wonder how much of this debate is
being governed by unconscious forces.
I wonder how much of what we're
experiencing is a manifestation of,
uh,
on,
we're,
we're cartography has not yet been a lot
of it.
What are you thinking about any
particular part of it?
Well,
I feel like is that the reason that the
ice,
imagine that you are arguments that are
based on research are so successful is
because people are expressing feelings
as opposed to cogent and researched
arguments.
It feels like corvair is a powerful,
dominant patriarchy and no one can deny.
I mean that there is power there such a
thing as power.
And there are people that benefit from
structures being as they are of course,
of course.
The point of those structures being the
way they are.
One of the things I've observed is that
whenever change is discussed,
you know,
and my tendency has always been to be
sympathetic towards movements that are
about change or empowerment of what
might be termed disadvantaged groups.
Um,
the changes or the that when you're
curious about the resistance of change
or the different difficulties that you
face when trying to bring about change,
look at who would be negatively
impacted,
where that change to be bought about.
And usually that means that there's some
people for vote.
You know,
conservatism makes sense to a particular
group of people.
One of the things I felt when I'm
reading a book was that,
you know,
like I,
I,
because I think you're coming from a
perspective of psycho analysis and it
rings very,
the language rings true and the analysis
rings true.
The Wa where I feel one question that I
was keen to bring to you because when
you talked about skateboarders in the
US,
I think it's the last bit one chapter
and that spirit of a,
a young people.
Yeah.
Courage and a willingness to try
dangerous things and to push forward.
Um,
I wonder how that sits with the idea of
uh,
an earlier passage in the book where you
talk about the gratitude that we should
feel for,
you know,
having time to read a book and the
ability to read a book and sort of
respect for the establishment and
systems that have been set up from which
we all benefit in it.
Because when I,
you know,
I,
I could find it difficult to dispute
your opinion about sort of a
journalists.
What would have been in the lexicon of
the day socially social justice warriors
and that kind of some what?
Rootless unresearched rage.
Like I identify what you're saying.
There are people that can't keep their
bedrooms tidy.
We have be careful before you let them
organize an economic system.
But like,
but,
but similarly like in where is change
going to come from?
Who are,
who is going to challenge tyranny.
Yeah.
Is it kind of thing.
Sure.
Those are the sorts of of twin forces
that we have to contend with across the
political spectrum.
So I could run through something quickly
to put the things that you just,
that you just brought up in,
in,
in perspective,
let's say.
Okay.
So the first thing is,
is that hierarchies,
if you're going to value some things
more than others,
then hierarchies are inevitable and you
have to value some things more than
others or you don't have anything going
to be a or strength for something.
What core competence or sure.
Whatever.
Whenever it happens to be the ability to
play the flute,
right?
It doesn't matter.
Why on my list.
Well,
what,
what do you know?
Obviously if you value music then you're
going to value some musicians more than
others because some are better.
So as,
and so you have to value things in order
to move forward in life.
And you have to value things in order to
have something valuable to produce.
But if you play out the value and the
social landscape,
you're going to produce a hierarchy.
And the problem with producing a
hierarchy is that a small number of
people are going to be successful than
the majority.
And a very large number of people aren't
going to be successful at all at,
at that particular thing.
It's inevitable.
So,
okay,
now,
so,
so you wanna say while we have to put up
with that,
because we need to pursue things of
value.
Okay,
fine.
So that's the right wing perspective is
that the hierarchy's are justifiable and
necessary.
Now the left wing perspective is,
yeah,
but wait a minute.
The problem with hierarchies is that
people stock up at the bottom and that
they tilt towards tyranny across time.
And that's also true.
And so you need that dialectic in
society between the right wing that
says,
you know,
we need the hierarchies and they're
useful and you should be grateful for
them and they structure you and give you
form and provide value.
And the left that says,
yeah,
but they exclude people and people stack
up at the bottom and that's dangerous to
the hierarchy itself and it,
it means that people might not have
opportunity and you have to say yes to
that.
The problem comes,
and this is the situation we're in right
now where the radical leftists,
and this is mostly a problem that really
permeates the universities.
The radical left is say,
yeah,
but all hierarchies are just tyrannical
power.
It's like,
oh no,
they're not.
Hierarchies are based on competence in
it functioning society and mostly our
society functions.
So you need it.
You can't go that far.
Now that doesn't mean that the
hierarchy's don't tilt towards self
interest and tyranny across time,
but that's a bad thing.
It's even a bad thing from the
conservative perspective so well,
so there's room for the left,
there's room for the left because the
poor will always be with us.
That's the reason that there's room for
the left and that the dispossessed need
a voice,
not least because there are talented
people among the dispossessed and if
they're stuck at zero,
everyone suffers because we don't have
access to their talents.
It's bad use of resources.
But on the right it's like,
no,
we need the damn value.
Hark is we need to be grateful for our
traditions and our structures because
they,
they stop us from degenerating into
chaos.
Also across the society,
numerous hierarchies emerge and at some
point decisions are being made about
which thing,
you know,
easy.
It being a brilliant flutist or
brilliant at tennis or brilliant owning
land or controlling energy resources or
dominate in financial systems,
which are the hierarchies that are most
important.
And also the,
uh,
what,
because like it's the way that resources
are designated and challenging.
Those hierarchies seems to become,
well almost impossible.
I'm,
when I was leaving the hospital,
the brilliant hospital,
they've been taking care of my mother
recently.
Yeah.
I sort of like,
you know,
the level of crisis and trauma and
tragedy there.
Excellent.
They've got this sort of thing.
Best doctors,
that guy might in griffith that operated
on her bowel.
He's like a fantastic surgeon.
He is in fact him that trump was quote
in when he talks about European
hospitals with blood spattered from
knife crime.
It was a sort of a mangling of a quote
that,
that this might in griffith a given and
they're sort of like,
I step outside like in,
I'm driving along along white chapel
road and there are um,
electronic advertising boards and it,
the uh,
you know,
that require energy.
Yeah.
So tell me to eat,
you know,
sort of a McDonald's or kit kats or
whatever and there's so much poverty on
that street.
There always has been in that part of
east London,
terrible poverty.
And I feel it was moments,
there are moments when I helicopter out
to the macro a perspective that no
individual can long hold or wait.
That can't be long born.
But in that moment I think,
why is this hospital struggling for
resources when we can afford to run
electronic adverts for Mcdonald's?
Who gets to decide how collectively and
individually do we determine where
resources and where power both in terms
of energy but also in terms of human
power and up.
How were these decisions made and as you
say,
among the dispossessed there is,
they were great resources,
great talent.
One would imagine if the research were
possible to the exact same degree is
there is power and talent among the
possessed because it's normally an
accident of birth that decrees and
reading about your early life in Canada
in a blue collar community and the sort
of the mental health issues and the
anger and agitation that grows there.
So much of that is about resources,
the dispossession of the native people
of that area,
the mental health issues if your friend
Chris like that.
For me,
we the are rising through these
hierarchies.
We that have experiences of both sides
of that line.
Well,
we are now challenging this evolutionary
force.
We are now in a position to talk about
these hierarchies,
how they're ordered and how they're
organized and whether there is room for
negotiation.
Well,
it's up to us to do that.
there's a risk in conservatism is
saying,
well this is how the cards have fallen.
And Yeah,
of course there is.
That is the risk and conservatives.
So how do we confront that?
While the risk is the,
the,
the hierarchies ossify and turn to stone
and then there's no mobility.
And the idea that that things can turn
to stone and they become tyrannical is
an extraordinarily old idea.
For example,
in,
in the story of Exodus,
the story of Moses.
So the Egyptian,
the Egyptians are portrayed in that
story as tyrannical conservatives
essentially,
right?
And they're masters of stone.
And Moses is a master of water.
And water is the thing that dissolves.
And so that drama's been played out in
these stories that are thousands of
years old.
And in the Egyptian story,
the ancient Egyptian story of Ocirus and
Horace,
oh,
cirrus is the old king who becomes too
rigid.
And what happens to him is that he's,
he's dismembered by evil.
That's the consequence.
And so even the Egyptians long ago knew
that the danger of hierarchies is they
become static and corrupt and
tyrannical.
And part of what we do in our ongoing
political dialogue and it and,
and when it's genuine dialogue is to
say,
well look,
are these,
do these systems have it,
we need them,
they're there not avoidable.
Uh,
do they,
are they functioning properly?
Are they loose enough so that people can
move?
Are they,
are they serving the broader good or
have they degenerated into something
that's too tyrannical?
Now,
you know,
you,
you kind of pointed to both of those in
the way you formulate that question
because you said,
look,
well my mum was in the hospital and she
needed care and so,
and I found a surgeon who was an
excellent surgeon.
And so,
so what you did there basically was take
a bow to the,
you bowed before the functional
hierarchy of the hospital and said,
look,
the greatest surgeon actually rose to
the top and thank God for that because
otherwise my mother would be dead.
It's like,
yes,
that's our competency hierarchy.
And it could be contaminated by tyranny,
in which case it would be the brother of
some powerful person who ended up with
the surgical position.
Right.
And then everyone dies.
And that does happen in many,
many cultures where nepotism or
connections define your position on
every oxys.
But then you said,
well,
but I went out to the hospital and I was
driving down the road and I saw what
appeared to be a misallocation of
resources.
And what we have to do about that is
have it,
have a discussion about it constantly.
It's like,
are we allocating resources to the
appropriate place?
Now the,
the other lurking problem there is to
what degree do we decide about the
allocation of resources by voluntary
effort,
by,
by planning,
and to what degree do we let the market
take care of it.
And that's also something that
continually requires negotiation.
Mom's kate might,
well,
I don't trust that.
Well that's the,
that's the question is able to talk
about it.
Like it's a neutral thing,
but it's just a conglomeration of
interests of the powerful,
well,
it's,
it's a bunch of things.
I mean it's that it can be that,
but it can also be the way that we
collectively value things.
Like,
let me give you an example.
Okay.
Look at our collective values and I'll
just quickly say this.
Yeah,
I heard this thing in Sweden.
They,
uh,
conduct regulate and control access to
alcohol at a state level,
like off licenses or liquor stores.
There's sort of socially run and like,
and they're not allowed to be advertised
in Sweden's,
you know,
Sweden,
I guess he's one of those havens of what
you might go,
I don't know what your views are.
Sweden by see a lot of stories about
Sweden.
The same,
a bit like a,
Hey,
we swayed and comes across as this,
I guess I sort of this sort of
postmodern democracy or in some respects
anyhow,
uh,
like I,
I thought it was curious that they
control alcohol in that manner and I am
envisaged that sort of breweries and
liquor distributors would say,
Hey,
that's not free market.
You're controlling access to,
you know,
people's access to alcohol as if somehow
the free market was neutral,
but they ease no neutral.
If the market is what has the power,
people's desires will be overly
stimulated.
People if people like,
if people have McDonald's advertise that
they're more alcohol,
advertise at them people,
Mcdonald's
and alcohol,
there has to be some more realizing
force.
There has to be something that's not
economically led.
There's not the manifestation of greed
that's in the conversation.
Someone in a secular society where there
is no reasonable or trusted voice of God
has to be able to say don't drink too
much alcohol.
Too Much Mcdonald's cause people will.
Okay.
So,
so let's see.
I think,
I think the most effective solution to
that problem is to have the economic
system run,
let's say by distributed individuals who
are themselves aiming at a higher good.
So I think the way that you,
the most effective way of regulating the
market so to speak,
is to improve the moral character of the
people who make up the market rather
than directly regulating the market.
And not that the market doesn't
necessarily need some regulation because
you might say,
well how about we don't devote alcohol
advertising to children under 10 most
people would agree that that's a
reasonable perspective.
And so that is limitation on market
forces.
And there are places that you can find
that,
um,
that that limitation being accepted by
almost anyone.
But,
but the part of what you're pointing to
is that if the only thing that's
governing the market is concerned for
pure market success than the market can
produce all sorts of excesses.
But I think what you want,
you want,
what you want is to help orient people
towards a transcendent good.
That's,
oh,
that's over and above market interest.
So you might say,
well,
what interests should you serve as
you're trying to be successful as a
comedian or in while you're trying to
make a living as a comedian say you
might want to make sure that you're
conducting yourself appropriately in the
marketplace.
You're concerned about yourself,
but also your future selves because you
have to take,
and that's partly why addiction is such
a catastrophe,
right?
Because it's great in the short term,
but it's not so good in the medium to
long run.
So you have to take care of yourself
and,
and your,
your iterations through the future.
You have to take care of yourself in a
way that you're taking care of your
family.
You have to take care of yourself and
your family in a way that you're
benefiting the community and that should
be foremost in your mind.
So then when you start to make economic
decisions,
even in your business,
you're not saying,
well I'm going to do whatever I can to
make as much money as I can.
You're going to say I'm going to do
whatever I can to make as much money as
I can while also making sure that I'm
taking care of myself and my future self
and my family and my community and being
like Grat,
grateful for all of that and serving it
properly.
And then I think the market can work
more effectively but still might require
some,
some discussion around the edges because
you know nothing is simple.
So the re the reason that I'm
concentrating on the individual and
individual development is because I
think that's the best way to do that
regulation.
I think that's important.
I think it's non negotiable I think is
necessary by also believe that if you
have a society this predicate it on the
some of the worst of human
behavior.
I lost the desire fear.
If last fear and desire are so high in
the mix,
if you're continually being prompted
towards onanism and consuming,
I think it's that individual improvement
will be insufficient.
I re I feel that your success is,
but I don't know it was based on,
but I feel that to a degree you've
contacted people and oh yeah,
I can improve my own life.
I can have a bit of personal authority
and autonomy and I think that's hugely
positive.
But if every time you step out of your
house,
every,
if every time you interface with society
or pick up your phone or look at a
screen,
the aspect of yourself as being
nurtured,
that's being invited to participate are
the lower aspects of your nature because
those are the most successful routes to
a person's decision making impulses.
And I think that it's difficult to
exceed.
I think it's difficult for these
individual projects to x to succeed.
I think that your,
you know,
certain people will,
that that message will take hold,
but others it won't.
So on to some degree we,
I feel like I ain't like a big fan of
regulation.
I understand your irritation about
what's being like this sort of a post
modern deconstruction list argument of
that destroy God that's destroy all
categories,
man.
Woman,
none of it's real.
I believe in essence the humours the day
or tease the gods.
I feel these things are present,
but I feel that we are already being
subject to a kind of invisible tyranny,
but it's already happening and I don't
think it's happening as a result of like
some critical theory postmarks just
like,
I feel like that,
that's not where power is.
That feels like it's sort of,
it doesn't feel like it's just fucking
powerful.
Was Glaxo Klein or like,
you know,
it's not as powerful as a Halliburton or
like,
you know,
these,
that's what I'm interested in.
Did his power,
real power and how power is functioning
and how power is the,
uh,
negatively impacting ordinary people?
Well,
I think it's perfectly reasonable to
point out that there might be multiple
ways that people experience tyrannical
oppression now because every hierarchy
is going to tilt towards tyrannical form
in its own particular way.
And so I've been concerned about what's
happening in the university on the
radical left and your concern,
the concern that you just brought up is
something like,
um,
overwhelming large scale corporate
dominance.
And I think that's also a reasonable set
of concerns.
You know,
it might not be for the best,
for example,
that all of our communication is
filtered through google.
That might be a bit too much.
Um,
the question is,
the question always is,
is what we can do about it.
And I think the answer,
the answer is an answer to that
actually.
The answer is we can lead people's
ability to communicate untrammeled and
so that's why I'm an advocate of free
speech.
We can lead people's ability to
communicate untrammeled so that we can
have intelligent discussions about those
problems as they emerge
and hopefully work towards solutions
because we can't just generate a
structure of rules that says,
well here's the 10 rules that are going
to deal without complex situation
because things change too rapidly for
that.
And the reason that freedom of speech as
far as I'm concerned is the paramount
freedom,
the paramount,
right.
Also the paramount moral obligation is
because it's through the,
it's through our ability to exchange,
to,
to um,
to exchange honest opinions that we
participate in the process that enables
us to keep tyranny of the sort that you
described and the sort that I described
out bay.
And so part of the reason that I've
taken the tack I have politically is
because,
well my government had the gall to
implement compelled speech legislation
without noticing what it was that they
were interfering with.
Cause you might say,
well well that's,
that's pretty much the end of it.
How do you keep tyranny at bay free?
The Ex,
the the proper exchange of ideas between
free individuals keeps tyranny at bay.
That's the best we've got.
It doesn't work perfectly.
It's also I think a gift that England
and in in large part has given to the
rest of the world to formalize and
codify that to put it into a body of law
to a wreck governmental structures that
are really predicated on that idea.
It's a remarkable achievement and it's
something we should be profoundly
grateful for.
Thank you.
I want to talk to you about the taking
that accepting praise on the behalf of
England there as an English person I
accept that there are two dragons.
Then there is the inner and the at least
unless until we've reached some
non-dualistic utopia where everything is
one.
There is the inner tracking of our own
desires and fears,
but I suppose like when we're talking
about management of resources,
is that a phrase that we could give the
came up earlier?
Like the where,
where does the attention need to go and
it's difficult.
Like you know me,
I suppose there's something about my
background that has led me to identify
as the Dragon.
Oh it's consumerism is turning people
into consumers because obviously as an
addict that's what I am,
a consumer and roll truck and Schumer.
And it seems that you,
with your background in academia,
this,
the,
this a neo Marxist post because,
but when I sort of like think about
aspects of socialism,
Eg,
you know,
people are working too hard.
You should only work four hours a day.
They should be time for fishing in the
afternoon,
which I think is in Das kapital.
Vicky talks about fishing in the
afternoon and for me that seems like a
very beautiful and fair and just idea.
Also I don't see them like wow,
I can imagine that they're irritating on
a campus,
particularly for somebody who's research
such a lot.
I don't see them as powerful.
That's my,
that's part of my intrigue I suppose.
It's comparable to when I was talking to
Sam Harris and other post do I have maya
but whom I go,
oh yeah,
but I don't like,
you know,
like when I'm talking to Sam Harris
about Islam,
I'll go be a,
but when like where's how
is Islam at gonna be like,
like I feel like it,
even if he's aware of Saudi Arabia and
Wahhabism like Saudi Arabia as an
economic entity,
they're not an Islamic entity in terms
of race,
go do some Islam.
It's like let's go do some business know
and like,
and so I suppose here what my,
my,
well I'm concerned mostly I'm concerned
mostly with the emphasis on,
on the collective identity rather than
the individual identity.
Like the process that you just
described,
I would say,
and this is the answer to the question
that you posed at the beginning of our
conversation is is there something
universal about the process that you
laid out?
And I think there is,
and I think it's at the core of
individual development and I think it's
the most powerful of forces.
And so I think that the individual
should be regarded as the proper locus
of evaluation.
And the problem I have with the
postmodern neo marxists types apart from
the fact that there were analysis tends
to lead to a kind of nihilism is that
because they're making the group the
paramount level of analysis,
this sort of thing gets ignored.
And I,
what I'm trying to do in my work,
we have a program called the self
authoring program that kind of steps
people through these 12 steps that you
just described.
First thing that people do is write
about their past all the emotional
experiences.
The second thing they do is take an
inventory of their personality,
faults and virtues so that they can
rectify the faults and capitalized on
the virtues.
And the third thing they do is chart a
course for the future that takes them
into account and others.
And so,
and I see it as a reflection of this
universal process that you just
described and I think it's the most
powerful form of transformation.
But more importantly,
I also think it's the one that risks
doing the least harm.
Like it hasn't heard anybody that you've
put yourself together.
It's just good,
right?
It's good for you.
It's good for the people that know you.
There's nothing about it.
And it's,
it's the right level of humility because
you took what you knew to be wrong in
your experience.
You took personal responsibility for it.
You made changes for yourself.
You didn't go around pointing the finger
at what was wrong with the external
world and trying to fix it.
Now look,
it could easily be that once you have
your act together,
or maybe even before,
you should be doing some things to
adjust political systems or sociological
systems.
But the problem with that is what makes
you think you can trust yourself?
You know?
And it's like,
well,
I'm compassionate.
It's like maybe,
maybe you're also envious of the
successful and the probability of that's
pretty damn high,
by the way.
And so you better know before you
express that compassion,
especially in the political domain,
whether or not that is contaminated by
things about yourself that you haven't
contended with.
Do you think an on declaration,
uh,
along those lines or specifically that
in the political field would be
refreshing?
Look,
I'll tell you one of the,
this is a very funny thing.
So the ancient,
the emperor of Ancient Mesopotamia.
So this is some of the earliest
political we have,
by the way.
Here's what they used to do to the
emperor.
Every new year's Day,
they would take him outside the walls of
the city.
So he was responsible for everything
within the walls.
Outside was chaos and the unknown,
they'd take them outside the city,
they'd strip him of all his emperor
garb.
So he's no longer emperor.
They'd make him kneel,
they'd humiliate him.
I think the,
if I remember correctly,
the priest would hit him with a glove
and say,
okay,
in the last year,
how name all the ways that you didn't
embody Marduk Marduk was the god of the
Mesopotamians.
And Marduk was the thing that took on
the great dragon of chaos.
And so it was the,
it was the responsibility of the emperor
to,
is to kneel down and say,
here's all the ways that I haven't been
acting out my proper self and had
brought the kingdom into disarray and
then he would be forgiven.
They would act out the reconstruction of
the cosmos.
That was the New Year's celebration.
And then he'd go in and try to be a good
king.
I like,
so,
yeah.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Absolutely.
It's like the confession of the emperor
is,
here's the way I haven't been good
and at any comparable,
uh,
and the powerful held up to that kind of
evaluation in,
we don't have rituals for that.
Well,
I suppose we don't acknowledge the
emergence of order from chaos.
We don't,
uh,
a merge [inaudible] knowledge,
divine principles.
So the powerful and light,
and I think this is possibly because of
a assumed meritocracy,
but I mean,
people that are in positions of power,
they're there for a reason.
You don't need to start stripping him
naked and take them outside of the city
and saying,
how often did you rank in that Oval
Office?
Every day get out.
Yeah,
well I think there might be something to
that.
And that's the danger of pride that goes
along with ascension in a hierarchy.
Well,
because I'm here in this position,
I must deserve it.
It's like,
yeah,
but there should still be something that
you're bowing down to.
And that might be the abstract idea of
sovereign authority itself.
If you think about it only
psychologically,
that's a figure that essentially has a
touch of divinity about it because it's
the on a key right now harm.
So that's the Queen,
the anointed and appointed monitor.
She represents,
you know,
by I suppose in a post secular nation,
she becomes the emblem of Britain rondon
the emblem of God on,
well,
I think,
I think it actually functions to some
degree in the same line.
Well,
I do think so because the queen your
queen in particular our queen as well
because maybe an alien.
No,
I mean I think Alyssa has been,
uh,
an embodiment of moral virtue.
I mean,
she's done a remarkable job over the
last,
what is it,
75 years now.
She's held herself to an incredibly high
moral standard.
And I think she does sit in the
background as emblematic of what
sovereign authority might look like.
Of course you postmodernist.
And this is an area where,
cause I,
you know,
I'm English and I can't get away from
the love of the Queen,
but I would also say that she is an
emblem of authority and of power and of
wealth and land ownership.
And that there is,
that there is an order that ought be
respected and can't be challenged every
so often this country sort of toys with
the idea of they're always
grateful when there's a wedding,
right?
Maybe he's this week so that no one has
to think,
is this right?
What are we paying for this bizarre
spectacle.
But it,
but it is useful to think about it in a
symbolic sense.
I mean,
one of the things that constantly
threatens the United States,
I think there should be four branches of
government,
legislative,
judicial,
executive,
and symbolic.
Because the problem in the United States
is the president keeps tilting towards
king,
you know,
the Americans like the idea of the first
family and the first lady.
And it's like,
yeah,
no,
and,
and kind of tilts towards a dynasty.
And you've seen that happen with the
bushes and the Clintons and it's not,
it's,
it's not a good thing.
And it might be nice to have someone
take the symbolic load off the president
and just act that out.
And your queen does that very nicely
because all of the pomp and circumstance
of the state and all the drama and
ritual of the sovereign can be played
out in that sort of dramatic space.
And your legislature and executive
branches can go off and do the
administration.
It's interesting that the,
uh,
the,
the dentist's ds exert themselves in a
sense.
It's a demonstration of your argument
that there are certain hierarchal
systems that find their way into
fruition regardless of regulation.
But then I suppose there's rational
reasons they would have the resources,
the experiences that can,
the connections.
Sure.
It's easier for them.
But that's also the d that's a danger to
a republic is the fact that,
and it's part of the potential
corruption of the state,
is that while it's easier for the
children of those who have authority to
have power,
and you don't want people attaining the
pinnacle of achievement because of
power,
he want them attending the pinnacle of
achievement because of competence.
Yeah.
And,
and those things always struggle.
They all,
and,
and it,
it,
it takes a society that's very awake to
stop the hierarchies from degenerating
into hierarchies of power because the
generation is the tendency.
Sure.
While it's easy,
it's easy.
Wba that fearsome and terrifying.
Uh,
you know,
faulconer pallium well,
and people have recognized that it's the
proclivity of hierarchies to,
towards tyranny for,
for really,
for thousands of years.
And I've seen that as a fundamental
danger to proper adaptation.
We need hierarchies.
Yes.
But they degenerate into tyranny and
they unfairly,
oh,
press.
It's like,
yes,
we have to be on guard against that.
But that doesn't mean that we call all
hierarchies tyrannies cause that's not
helpful.
Or we call all productive activity
service in the,
in the service to the oppressive
patriarchy because that's seriously not
how helpful and we don't dispense with
hierarchies because then people don't
have anything to do.
So yes.
So I see,
I get the beam out your iheart like so
say if the individual is tuned,
if the individual is at channel,
I'm going to to,
I like the prayer of Saint Francis.
I like it as a model.
They invites us to find the reverse of h
a defective characteristic that we all
sin that we might be living out to
become a channel of some inherent
goodness.
The thing that's one of the things
that's interesting rolled out or two
things actually.
The first is the word sin means to miss
the target.
It's an archery term.
So that's quite,
that's a very interesting way of
thinking about it because it means that
there is a target,
there is a target.
That's the thing.
But the next thing is,
and this,
this comes right out of that,
is it's very useful to become aware of
your faults because as soon as you pause
it a fault,
you pause it the opposite by merely
saying,
well,
that's a fault.
You're saying implicitly,
while there's something that's the
opposite of that,
so out of your recognition of faults,
immediately some clarity of virtue
develops because you might say,
well,
this is a fault and I really know it.
It's like,
great,
you've got some bedrock there.
Whatever the opposite of that fault is,
you might not know what that is,
but whatever the opposite of that fault
is,
is a virtue.
And then you might say,
well,
I have 20 faults.
It's like great.
The opposite of the personality that has
all those 20 faults is the virtuous you,
whatever that might happen to be.
Well,
great.
Then you've then you've conjured out of
the devil,
um,
ah,
a redeemer.
It's something like that.
I like that.
And the UN doubtedly both in terms of
cosmology and fleeting morality,
there is chaos,
there is vastness,
but there are also patterns.
There are patterns that emerge and
whether you call that pattern male or
love or beauty,
there are various patterns and I feel
that there is,
there is something to get in alignment
with.
There is a choon,
there is harmony,
there is melody,
there is grace.
We're not totally rested.
All you're using their musical musical,
uh,
um,
what would you call analogies are
meaningful representations.
That's what music expresses is to have
all of that in harmony because people
love music because of that,
you know,
in those patterns because music,
you think about music,
it is the harmonious interaction of
patterns and you just described all
those positive,
uh,
what would you call them?
Spirits.
That's a good way of thinking about it
as patterns,
while they are patterns.
And then you might think that there's a
pattern that's composed of all of those
patterns.
Well that's what you're after.
You're after the pattern that's composed
of all those patterns.
Yes,
absolutely.
And you want to put yourself in harmony
with that and that is a real thing.
That's a real thing.
You can feel that.
So it's what keeps you alive essentially
when you're trying to become conscious.
Yes,
yes.
There is something important happening.
I feel like what we were saying before
about the acknowledgement of difference
need an infor inferiority.
That is something that definitely not
while we should be actually,
well,
and this is part of what the radical
leftists keeps saying is,
well,
we should celebrate diversity.
It's like,
yes,
but what that means first is the
admission that people actually differ.
You know,
always you don't have diversity.
It's like,
I'm glad there are conservatives.
I'm glad there are leftists.
The conservatives run things,
the leftists invent them.
It's like good and they're really
different.
Those people like you know,
if you,
if you have a group that's all
conservatives and they're going down the
right path,
they're going to go down that path
really fast,
but if they're going down the wrong
path,
they're not going to be able to think
laterally and figure out how to get out
of it.
If you have a group of of left leaning
creative types,
it's like they're going to come up with
a hundred ideas,
but the probability that they'll
organize in a stable hierarchy and
implement those effectively is zero.
It's they're going to have to call over
the conservatives.
It's like,
look guys,
we finally got a good idea.
You can have one idea cause you're
conservatives run with it and then they
can all run with it.
And so it's really good that we have
people who are like that on both sides
of the distribution because otherwise
the,
the creative types would sit around and
come up with new ideas until they starve
to death in squalor.
And while exactly.
And the Conservatives would just awesome
fi and,
and you know,
run down a road that got narrower,
narrow,
and they'd all end up stuck between two
cliffs and that'd be the end of it for
both of them.
Thesis,
antithesis,
synthesis.
We require synthesis.
This is how does the interplay of
opposites.
Actual opposites.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The Yin Yang that yes,
there needs to be necessary collusion
between distinction,
but for that to happen,
there needs to be acknowledgement and
recognition of difference in a trying to
achieve a quality with the Annihilation
of category is not successful.
Yes.
That's that.
That's exactly right.
That is not a successful route.
Thank you.
Duck tapped.
Professor Jordan Peterson.
We have good chats that way.
That was great.
Yeah,
that was really good.
Absolutely.
Thanks for inviting me back.
Thank you.
Thank you for the time.
Thank you,
Tami.
Thank you.